pop
[Musique]
le 45e salon de genève n'a pas failli à
sa réputation celle de présenter des
nouveautés cette année quinze voitures
que automoto essaiera ultérieurement
étaient proposés à la presse et aux
visiteurs
mais le grand événement fut la
présentation imprévu de celle que
personne n'attendait encore la 604
peugeot la 604 peugeot est une 6
cylindres la carrosserie est assez
différente de la 504 les lignes sont
plus cassés
c'est une simple as 15 chevaux longueur
4 m 72 4 vitesse boîte automatique
vitesses annoncées par le constructeur
182 km
[Musique]
la nouvelle renault la r30 ts est une
berline cinq places 4 portes
6 cylindres en v direction assistée pour
la première fois au monde une voiture de
grande diffusion est présenté avec le
tout à l'avant vitesses annoncées 185
kilomètres heure la r30 ne se veut pas
une voiture de m mais une grande
routière qui touchera un public
international bénéficiant de
l'implantation renault à travers le
monde
l' escort rs 2000 vient s'ajouter à la
gamme des ford escort 75
elle possède un moteur ford plus
puissant
la nouvelle volkswagen polo n'a que 3
mètres 50 ce qui est un avantage certain
pour se garer la consommation 7 litres 3
aux 100 km la nouvelle rolls royce la
camargue est plus sobre
la calandre est moins riche en chrome
que celle de ses aînés confort et
performance
la maserati quatre portes et une voiture
de grand tourisme qui se déplace à plus
de 210 kilomètres heure c'est une 6
cylindres traction avant longueur c'est
m 13
une voiture sport 5 places la lancia
beta monte carlo se place entre la bête
a coupé et la stratos la bêta
monte-carlo offre deux places d'un
confort raffiné puissance fiscale 20
chevaux longueur 3 mètre 80
sa vitesse la fel baer fait partie des
voiture folle folle folle sur cette
carrosserie tout aluminium très rétro a
été monté un moteur ferrari 12,6 leur
boîte à cinq vitesses 235 km heure en
pointe poids 1000 kg attention décollage
les 100 kilomètres heure en 4 secondes
la passeure est une petite voiture qui
nous vient des états unis longueur 4
mètres 35 largeur 1 mètre 95
elle offre une forme compacte a3 porte
avec sa vitre panoramique la jeep
nouvelle version revue et corrigée par
lévis capote plus hermétique confort
presque assurée d'une manière générale
la tr 7 continue la gamme dtr que les
amateurs de voitures de sport
connaissent bien
avec sa forme ardila tr cette offre le
confort d'une limousine et la tenue de
route d'une véritable voiture sport la
tr 7 est une deux places l'alfasud
nouvelles nées d usine alfa romeo a la
particularité d'être une berline quatre
portes est de ressembler à un coupé
c'est une 4 cylindres opposés
la vitesse de pointe est de 160
kilomètres/heure l'alfasud est
commercialisé en france depuis quelques
mois
[Musique]